Olivia jade has broken up with her
boyfriend
Jackson Guthrie a source tells ET the 19
year-old daughter of Lori Lachlan and
fashion designer Massimo Gianelli is
single again and her friends are
surprised by the split quote Olivia's
friends were shocked when her
relationship ended with her boyfriend
because he was actually great for her
and was a real support
he's pretty low-key and wanted to help
her stay out of the limelight and move
on I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I would I really want
that for them Olivia Jade and the
musician were linked together before her
parents were accused of paying $500,000
in bribes to get both her and her older
sister 20 year-old Bella admitted to the
University of Southern California as
recruits for the crew team even though
neither of them participated in the
sport I just want them to have that
experience and get that education and
have a degree to fall back on Lori and
Massimo both pleaded not guilty last
month
I'm literally moving into college today
the source also tells ET Olivia still
wants to return to USC to save face
while it seems odd after everything
that's happened she is concerned about
her image and seems to want to prove she
can complete the classes and graduate
the source added quote after being
dropped by her brands she's worried she
won't ever get back on track without an
education I do want the experience of
like gamedays partying I don't really
care about school as you guys meanwhile
the source says her relationship with
Lori is still strained for the most part
she's cut herself off from her mother
and is going out and partying a lot as
for Lori our source says she's gearing
up for the legal battle ahead quote she
is ready for her day in court and just
wants to take the stand and tell her
side of the story
Lori also wants to focus on rebuilding
her family the best
she can earlier this month a source told
ET that the fuller house star strongly
believes she shouldn't face jail time
quote she truly feels it was all a
misunderstanding I think the likelihood
that Laurie spends prison time is very
very high because of the seriousness of
the crime and the amount of money that
we're dealing with here
[Music]